Corie from your time at film school and
also you know having riding instructors
talk to you when you were in college
mm-hmm
did you feel embraced or discouraged
some thinking about like a Ray Bradbury
interview I saw when he said he advised
a lot of people not to to take writing
classes because he felt that they were
always discouraged ah um how did you
feel as a student really encouraged did
you okay but that's actually why I would
have people think twice about taking
those classes because there's fixed
mindset encouragement and there's growth
mindset encouragement and so you know
the very first teacher that I let me
step back a lot of teachers that I know
have a philosophy that the more you
write the better you'll become and so
they're in job is to encourage writers
and yeah I mean you you're gonna point
out things are not doing right you're
gonna criticize you're gonna but you
always couch that with three compliments
you know like sugar and all thing the
other day your job is to make these
people feel like they can do this that
they have what it takes and then I'll
keep them writing and the more they
write the better they become and I don't
I don't do that as a teacher for a
variety of reasons first as I said I
think most writers when they first start
writing they see significant improvement
because when we first start writing we
make lots of really dumb mistakes that
we don't know we don't know what we
don't know so if you're if you're
somewhat open to feedback and criticism
and you're trying to get better and you
have reasonably smart or really smart
people in your life reading your stuff
and giving you feedback I do think
people really start to make a real
improvement then they hit a plateau
it'll stay on forever and that plateau
is where the more they write the more
the higher the pile of some early flawed
scripts are because if they have
intuitive weaknesses or conceptual
weaknesses you can keep writing as much
as you want you're just gonna keep
making those mistakes so I don't believe
I know writers who've been on it for 10
or 12 years and what they're writing
today isn't really any better than what
they're writing eight years ago so I
don't believe I believe the more you
write the better you become
without the right training and tools is
for most people kind of a Santa Claus
Tooth Fairy fantasy further I do think
it's really important
to have someone in your life for people
in life who who believe in you and love
you and support you and when you're
feeling down they're like no you can do
this and they can be the wind in your
sails when the wind you know goes away
and you just sort of lose confidence and
you lose your way I think that's
absolutely essential I would never do
that as a teacher I don't think someone
should pay for that and also I don't
want someone become dependent on me so I
want them to find people in their lives
and ultimately themselves to be able to
have that you know confidence in love
and further I think that the fixed
mindset confidence is always pointing
out what you're doing right and
complimenting and you're so good you're
so good you have what it takes that's so
fixed mindset I think the growth mindset
is there's tools that you can learn and
let me teach you a tool and so like what
is your biggest weakness as a writer
let's spend four weeks doing nothing but
training on that tool and then we're
gonna have you write a scene or a
sequence and you're going to see and or
you give to other people and they're
gonna see oh my god you're you're
suddenly better at this thing and then
you're like oh that's the confidence I
want to give someone I had a weakness
identified it or it was identified for
me I had a specific training regimen I
came out the other end stronger at that
and maybe you're not as strong as you
need to be yet but you can keep training
and you can keep training and you
realize I can get to the point where I'm
as good as I need to be okay now Amy
I've got six other things I need to do
that on and so maybe just couldn't take
six months or a year that's growth
mindset confidence that's what I want to
instill in people so my experience for
the most part in film school was very
gentle everyone came in and told us you
can make this you can do this you're
amazing and in my class there were 12 of
us three of us went on to have careers
and nine didn't and one thing that the
three of us had in common
we weren't smarter than the I certainly
wasn't smarter than some of the others
or a lot of the others we didn't work
harder honestly I didn't work that hard
in film school I'm not proud of that but
I had a lot of Presta nation issues what
we did have in common is we all had a
man
not the same manager but y'all had a
manager who in their own way said you're
not as good as you think you are hmm and
you need to get better in certain skill
sets and I can help you do that
and in my case it it was a year of
working with this manager turning
weaknesses that I didn't know I had or I
did know I had interests RAM that's a
big reason why I teach because I had
access to that if I didn't I would have
been like the nine who didn't I mean I I
had certain things I was inherently
really good at and I had certain things
I was inherently really bad at and I had
things I didn't know I was bad at and no
one in film school was really helping me
with that it was it was the manager who
did that work so I I think yeah classes
were they just sort of tear you down and
discourage you should be avoided at all
costs I know people who have troubles
with their writing and and they don't
feel confident and they find the teacher
that gives them confidence and support
and they love that teacher and they
become addicted to that teacher and
they'll take and it's a good business
model for the teacher because they'll
keep taking classes because they're
taking classes to feel that feeling
right but that's not solving the problem
if I can make you feel confident or good
about your writing or special I can make
you feel like you can get there that
doesn't mean anything what matters is
when you can feel that way and the way
you'll feel that way in my opinion is
through proving to yourself that you're
making progress and confidence through
your training so it sounds like this
sort of military style you know boot
camp breaking you down is gonna harm
someone but at the same time too much
hand-holding and babying and oh you're
one of our prize you know that sounds
like that's also damaging and like that
I think that's highly addicting but it's
not gonna and you're gonna feel good but
that's like junk food
she'll taste good but it's not
nutritious it's not making you healthier
so I'm wondering with this manager do
you think you were more open to hearing
then than some of the other people I
mean I mean if you say that you feel
that you were on the same level right
right well they're different maybe
that's a great that's a great question
and as a
said earlier I was such an incredibly
fixed mindset person so I was absolutely
not open to here I'm okay I got very
lucky so this is what happen and and I
want to share this because I try to
share us as many riders as I can because
I think this is a really important story
and there's something here that they can
do which I would highly recommend so
what happened is I wrote this script and
you